hello everyone and welcome to the
highlight show of clutch chairs
hopefully you were able to check out the
games but if not I will take you to the
key moments of the final two days and
explain to you how this tournament work
so this was a tournament put on by the
san luis chess club that involved the
top four American chess players Hikaru
Nakamura Wesley so Fabiana Caron and
linear Dominguez so first it started
with a match between Fabiano Carwin and
then your Dominguez and Hikaru Nakamura
and Wesley so eventually Fabiano Caruana
and Wesley solve on their respective
matches and were facing in the final so
the way the class just works the first
four games are scored normally which
means the win is a point a dries half a
point and loss is zero but there are
also clutch games at the end of the day
so after four games are a two game after
the four rounds there are two games
after the first day those two games are
worth two points for a win and one point
for a draw and $2,000 each and the final
day each Wayne in the clutch game is
worth three points and one and a half
for a draw so even if someone is
trailing behind by two or three points
they still have the chance to win the
match so let's get started with day one
with our game between Wesley so and
Fabiano Khurana
so this was a very exciting match and
there were a lot of interesting game and
some key points that we're gonna go
through I'm not going to show you the
games from the beginning to the start
but just the highlights so let's get
started with this first game very
Fabiana corona is black and what's this
so has the white pieces so let's start
in this position so Fabiana has
sacrificed couple of pants and started
in a royal office that the position is
quite wild as you can see the white King
is quite weak but why it is up a lot of
pawns because he 527 96 so Fabiana
exchanges and brings his rook into the
game so even though white is up a couple
of pounds it's not so easy for him to do
anything called easily win the game
especially with this exposed King on h2
and this annoying pin on the second rank
so he grabs another pawn but now he has
to face Queen h4 and simply moving the
bishop so there are no tactics
the back rank for example if night of
for them white would simply take
followed by checkmate
so to avoid all this find behind a place
Bishop e7 I wisely decides to take this
annoying night and Bishop h4 and now
actually even with all this extra pants
this was a critical moment where Weston
made the natural move over up g2 because
he wants to work on the second rank
protecting his King and protecting the
night but unfortunately after taking on
that for roque one night is him who has
to find only moves to make a drum so
Knight f3
because rock h1 was threatening mate so
check has to block threatening crook e3
and draw by repetition so the day
started with a drum with Fabiano the
black pieces so in the next game he had
the white pieces so let's go ahead and
start on move 14 so this was a Berlin
and we note Berlin has a pretty bad
reputation for being very dry but
actually it leads to very interesting
positions so once again Fabiana decides
to sacrifice a pawn playing g4 and
giving up his h3 pawn with the idea of
playing east 6 and threatening to open
up the position for his rooks and trying
to get his rook to d7 so of course
taking this pawn is impossible because
the knight is hanging and king f7
doesn't work because of 95 and the rook
Hanks so instead
Wesley took on g3 rook g4 and rook d7
which was Fabiano's plan so here Wesley
made a key mistake he played rook c8
which is a very passive move defending
his pawn instead what he should have
done as pointed out by Fabiano is take
give up his 7 ranked pawns but play
against the white king by bringing the
rook to f8 and playing against this King
and this pin
but instead rook c8 was played by B&O
takes and now Wesley blunders Knight of
fate lying for rook h1 with a very
strong thread of ruke h8 and trying to
checkmate and it looks like 96 would
actually work because the rook is
hanging
so if Czech Blackwood chick but now 95
and the rook is under attack the rig is
defended and there's no way to stop the
checkmate and in this position Wesley
simply resigned so this gave Fabiano a
full point lead so in the next game
Fabiana had the black pieces and this
was a Benoni
which is an opening that Fabiano likes
to use in his games even though he
thinks even a good banana is not a is
still a bad banana so in this position
Queen b6 was played and and so in this
position actually white blundered with
rotate 3 allowing for 94 and now we see
that even though if 4 was such a
defended square there is a Miss
coordination because he played Bishop g7
but after something like 94 it should be
2 and we see that the queen is
overworked so instead Bishop g7 was
played and now takes on d2
22 and we entered this in this position
where black is simply up upon but that
ventures didn't stop here and here
Fabiana blundered in turn and Wesley
actually missed it and he never said
this that he could have won a piece
simply by playing f4 in this position
and the Fabiana realizes right after the
game but in the interview was they
admitted that he never saw this a this
option which is maybe a good thing
because when you realize you miss such a
thing it can really tell you but we see
that there is no way for the rook to
move anywhere to save this night so he
would have simply one upon so instead h4
was played and like is still a pawn but
there's a limited amount of pieces and
not a lot of time left as you can see
less than 5 minutes for each
so Leslie managed to hold it dry here so
giving up upon going into a rogue and
game so wielding a fortress of I've been
a decides to give up his C pond but
there is no way to make progress here
there's no way to break through and the
game ended in a draw in opponent game so
let's move on to our next game which was
a very interesting strategic battle so
let's start on move 16 where Wesa placed
e4 takes and instead of simply taking
back his sacrifices in exchange it takes
24 and plays for a long-term
compensation because the position is
closed so this rooks are kind of useless
and blacks minor pieces will be quite
strong against this wicked King so King
h1 Queen f4 g6 stopping any Knight h5
jumps so here if I be on a decides to
give the exchange back 92 but
unfortunately he missed his key move of
Queen III which is really annoying so he
cannot take only three because now he
will allow his opponent to have this
annoying past ban and lose their three
pounds instead he goes rookie one loses
a pawn but still manages to draw the
game with the pawn back so a lot of
chances for black because of this pawn
structure but b3 a key move impossible
to take the pawn because the knight is
hanging so 95 was plenty instead and
they exchanged into pretty equal night
and game where everything was exchanged
and they were very quickly the game
ended in a draw so next the score now is
plus 1 for Fabiana but Knight up next
are the clutch games which are worth 2
points for it for a win so winning this
is actually very important because it
would allow it Fabiano to either take a
three point lead or with a la Wesley to
lick front Fabiana
so let's go to our next game where
Wesley so has the white pieces
so if you take a look at this position
this is quite another uneventful game
actually
so black does have this past pawn on c4
but white has this very strong
centralized bishop so he goes Bishop d6
Bishop f6 is played and white simply
takes the black cannot take with the
Queen because check losing the pawn so
he has to take with the pawn the black
still has this annoying fast one which
is quite dangerous but because of the
Queen's on the board and how weak this
King is white is always going to have
some counter play so the game ended in a
draw quite quickly so e4 and just
allowing for a repetition so quiet
uneventful game so we're entering the
last round of the day of day 1 in this
match where Fabiana is still leading by
a point but there's still a clutch game
ahead which means Wesley could still
leapfrog his opponent which he did with
a win so let's go start with new move 19
so this was a very complicated game
Fabiana has the white pieces started as
a real office so white goes before
trying to open up the center takes rook
e6 pinning the knight on c6 pinning the
Queen so the rook is no longer hanging
bishop swings back rooks come back so
not taking only 5 because after this
this is starting to look quite
unpleasant because c5 is hanging the
pawn structure is weak and white has a
really good play for for the exchange so
instead play C 6
now the rook is hanging so here Fabiana
had this amazing move of 94 because
Sumter something like this let's say
take let's say take take take Y
structure is just amazing because
there's so many witnesses in the
position White has no weaknesses
instead he played rook age 5 going for
adventures and he even admitted that he
quite very risky and this race did not
pay off so 96 and now the work is
getting trapped so obviously when when I
teach for four reasons so Fabiana
decides to sacrifice but Wesley defends
quite easily because why it just simply
doesn't have enough so he decides to
take and take on g3 so usually we don't
exchange bishops for tonight but the
problem is after take these pants are
just not going anywhere because it's
going to be really hard to try to
promote them in the end game and the
king in the night especially even the
King alone will do a very good job of
stopping them so a five so there are a
few repetitions in the games of course
black is not going to repeat but in a
Russian school of chess always repeat
once so rookie tune so he repeats one
more time and now a really nice shot in
the position I have to threatening made
on h1 forcing to take but after check
flag simply wins the rook so Fabiana
played a few more checks but black will
simply stop the checks with the Queen
going to h6 and the game will be over
quite quickly so this was day one and
because of this win of Wesley was able
to leapfrog Fabiano and also collect
$2,000 extra just for winning this game
and the other two thousand dollars that
were in Game five they spilled over into
games eleven and twelve and day two and
speaking of day two
let's move on and see what happened then
so now let's dive into day two so the
day started with Wesley so with a full
point I had Fabiano karana so the first
four games have the normal scoring so to
speak
which means each win is worth one point
so Fabiano starts with the white pieces
and let's move on to let's start on move
xxx so we'll start in the middle of the
game so we have another Berlin so very
typical Berlin structure so white play
see six probably under fun some really
nice tactics here he takes an amazing
move ninety-three so now it's taking on
c3 is actually very unpleasant because
this pawn structure is just atrocious
instead the knight move back
take on d3 and white one a pun and he
went on to win the game and I will show
you how so the pants were exchanged the
h4 really nice move h5 fixing the pawn
on h6
so 97 and here key mistakes King the 7
route d3 and simply winning a piece
because it doesn't matter where the kid
the King goes white will take this and
it's going to be a fork and the game is
over because white is just up a piece so
now the score is even and let's move on
to our second game where Wesley has the
white pieces so it was another Roy Lopez
and it was a very crazy game very
up-and-down game where which Wesley was
quite upset about for a very good reason
so let's start on move 15 where if I be
on a place to see if I move with Yasir
did not like at all because let's check
out this Bishop sewed if I was played so
this was a beautiful game by Wesley so
unfortunately there was a big blunder at
the end so strategically this is just a
beauty to enjoy so night of 5 getting
the two bishops when you were in the
night back a rook lifts always a great
thing to do in chess the route can swing
to either side of the port so the knight
on c4 just completely dominant playing
a5 which not only stops the Knights from
going to be six but also just kills this
Bishop rook swings back to the other
side now it's expand is hanging Bishop
moving to the other side g4 and because
of Queen side in the center are prefixed
White is looking to expand on the King
side efore so played immediately by
Fabiana because it's looking for counter
place or anything because expert
desperate times call for desperate
actions so h4 sobbing the knight from
jumping to g5 putting the bishop on the
long time
swinging the rock back ready to go g5
again desperate actions trying to create
some kind of counter play so the knight
jumps into the game rock only moves
grabs a pawn because what else is there
to do quindi 894 so Fabiana decides to
sacrifice and bring the bishop into the
play so here in this position
Wesley plays an amazing move f6 an f3
and now funny enough the knight is
trapped in the middle of the board so
Bishop e3 ship back so we reach this
position where I'm by the assembly upper
rook and he plays this funny-looking
move 23 huge alarms went off for the
commentators because something feel all
about it because if you look at the
position we see this possible tactic and
after Knight f2 rookie 3
unfortunately White's position is
falling apart and this was a huge
blunder by Wesley so and we're a
heartbreaking blunder in a completely
winning position so it takes takes and
black is just taking everything taking
all the pawns with checks when it's a
piece so now instead of being down a
rock is up for pawns
so the rest is just a matter of
technique I will just show you the rest
of the game so there are some checks in
the position but there's no real threats
cannot take on g6 because of the check
so it's not even that so simply takes
everything and at some point Wesley just
gave up so this a lot so with this one
Fabiana will actually was leading by a
full point because he was a full point
ahead but he won the first two games so
the next game was quite uneventful but
let's take a quick look at the quick
look so another Berlin but the not a
very exciting one so g3 and this is very
common to push this H pawn so we're just
going to see how all the pieces were
exchanged and not too much happen in the
game so we don't have to spend a whole
lot of time because we want to get
through the exciting games
simply takes just a lot of exchanges
bishop's wins back and few more moves
nothing too interesting nothing to
really talk about and they came to send
it in a drop okay and still
Fabiana was leading by a full point and
there was one more regular scoring game
to go and two more clutch games to come
up so this game was just completely
dominated by Wesley software he played a
beautiful move so the in this game was
so so just completely dominated his
opponent so let's start in this position
so it looks kind of messy but the first
thing that stands out is this bishop
again which is reminiscent from the game
was uh two games ago so nice move
tonight c5 taking advantage of the pin
so g3 takes takes and just ignores it
because she takes the king hides behind
the pawn and there is no attack take
ghosted open file h3 there's simply no
attack and blacks position is just
busted ninety five a really nice move
exchanging the knights going into
opposite colored bishop position where
this is the bishop for black they take
c3 and simply check and the game is over
opieop seven King g8 we just have simple
made into so really nice me nice win by
Wesley so and so now the going into the
clutch games the score was even and
Wesley so actually only needed to win
one game because he had the better tie
breaks and the reason he had better tie
brace is because you want a clutch game
which gave him the upper hand so let's
take a look at the next game where
Wesley saw has the black pieces so in
this game
Fabiano got really outplayed so this was
a royal Lopez and black just has a trim
position if you look at the structure at
the dominant Knight to a file so far
behind it tries for the last trick going
Knight b6 hoping his opponent takes but
of course he just ignored Wes it just
ignores this Knight
and we know that rooks on the second or
seven ranked are just killer because
they just attack everything on that rank
it takes another pawn and I have to last
nice shot simply because you don't take
on f2 you check King cannot escape has
to block but after take take b2 and if
route B 392 picking up the rope and
cleaning the pawn so after rook e1 was
played Fabiana resigned and actually so
actually Wesley one and he clinched the
title but neither one of the players
near because they didn't and read their
contract so they thought the next game
is very important and could give Fabiano
the opportunity to tie the match so
let's take a look at what happened in
the final game so here a Fabiana with
the black pieces played a beautiful game
takes on a 324 sacrificing an exchange
but we will look at the structure this
Knight is just going to be a beautiful
majestic piece f5 and again just like in
the other exchange sacrifice we saw the
rooks are quite useless because they
don't have open files the night comes
into a plate and this King is just so
weak check 94 when f4 attacking the rook
King g7 black doesn't have to rush and
just going for the exchange because that
night is just dominating like is up a
couple of funds already and there's
nothing white can do so g4 and now the
king is coming in and the cape King only
five beautiful piece as is the night
only four so Wesley decides to sacrifice
the exchange back but unfortunately
there is not much hope for him
so h5 giving up the pawn but after check
all the pawns fall so a beautiful clutch
win by Fabiana Khurana but unfortunately
for him the match was already decided
but even so he picked up quite a bit of
money for winning this and he is bonus
for winning clutch
in this tournament came up to $18,000 as
opposed to Wesley so whose bonus wins
came to $10,000
so the winner Wes Lazar picked up
additional $30,000 for winning the event
whereas Fabiana picked up another
$20,000 for winning it so great
performance by both players really
amazing games and really fun chess for
all the fans to enjoy thank you everyone
for tuning in I hope you enjoyed this
video make sure you're joining us on
June 6 for the same format that will
involve the top four Americans as well
as world champion Magnus Carlsen Maxima
telegraph that one Aronian and Alexandra
Christian